hello everyone my name's mark price I
work for a company called L Mike's
exchange we've built a low latency FX
exchange platform this talk kind of came
out of a lot of the work we've done in
the last six months or so to tune the
operating system to achieve as low
latency and predictable latency as we
could so I'm just going to take you
through that their learnings that we got
from that I should qualify first off
this is the Linux operating system and
the concepts will exist for Windows and
OS X but the names will be different so
if you run
OS X in production this may not be that
useful for you but there you go okay and
first off a disclaimer it's not the
operating systems fault then it gets in
the way Linux is a really good
general-purpose OS that does a lot of
things but because it has so many target
platforms phones embedded desktop laptop
service it has to generalise low latency
what we use it for is a very special use
case so sometimes it's necessary to
provide some hints the operating system
for how you want it to act in order to
get the results that you need so why
should you care about this kind of thing
it is quite niche so these techniques
are useful in some scenarios so first
off most applicable to my company are
low latency applications where you need
very fast and consistent response times
and these are typically where your
system end-to-end response times are
under a millisecond that's the kind of
area you want to be in when these these
techniques really come into use also if
you have very compute intensive
workloads and you know that you're going
to get benefit from just giving as much
CPU resource as possible to your
programs or if you have very long
running jobs and you know that making
sure that always-on CPU is going to
shave a little bit of time off at the
end so when the u.s. gets in the way
they tends to manifest itself as system
jitter so it is defined by the
dictionary as a slight irregular
movement variation or unsteadiness in an
electrical signal or electronic device
but more really
ethically what you see is a variation in
response time latency so if your
customer is making requests to your
system which do or should do the same
amount of work from as far as they're
concerned and they expect to see
consistent response times which is you
know fair enough and if I don't see them
it's kind of a bad customer experience
and so what you'll tend to see in most
systems is a long tail in response time
so the vast majority of requests can be
serviced very quickly and in a
consistent time but your worst case is
often way out to the end and that's the
kind of thing that we want to try and
minimize with these techniques so how do
you go about dealing with this first off
the bad news is you have to take care of
all the low-hanging fruit and this is
generally going to be a software problem
so if you're on a managed runtime like a
JVM if you have garbage collection you
need to deal with that somehow so a
couple of different techniques you can
either go DC free so you have to rewrite
all your code use object pooling and
that kind of thing or you can go down
the commercial route and pay for a
different runtime like thing which will
just take care of that problem for you
if you have any slow IO in your
latency-sensitive path you need to
either upgrade your hardware or apply
caching or change your workflow so that
you can do IO out-of-band essentially so
that it's not going to cause you undue
latency and once your response times
when you've made these kind of changes
are down under about the ten millisecond
millisecond mark then you can start
using these kind of techniques to see
what improvements you can make and also
you need to make sure your code is
running it sounds obvious but as we'll
see it may not always be the case and
first off before we even start making
any of these kind of changes
measurements are really really important
so we need to validate that any changes
we're making are having the right effect
and especially that changes you require
in one place are the correct changes to
make in another place ideally you need
to have some entering tests which are
going to mimic your whole
request lifecycle through your system
using realistic load so Lmax we record
all our inbound production traffic with
a network tap and then were able to
replay that back into our performance
environment at varying rates and
multipliers of load so that we know that
we're exercising the code and the
hardware and the system in a realistic
fashion so we haven't just kind of
created this idealized view of what we
think production load is so that's
really important when we are making
changes to systemic things it's really
important to isolate your changes you
all have to do one thing then run with
that for probably the rest of the day
see how that changes the measurements
that you've made because if we start
lumping in more than one change and
there's a negative effect then you need
to unwind that and do them one at a time
any way to find out and bisect where the
problems come from so if you just do one
thing at a time then you never have to
do that unwinding which is useful so
before talking about exactly how we
minimize system juicer it's going to do
a slight refresher on what hardware
looks like these days and so and just to
define a few terms that we'll talk about
so the chef's see is the physical piece
of slab of metal that and you put into
iraq in your data center and the chassis
will have peripheral devices like
network cards or disks typically you'll
have multiple processor sockets on that
chassis and each sake is treated as a
Numa node and it will have a bank of
local Ram which are connected by the
memory interconnect so that the the
total memory there is available to all
the CPUs but there is kind of a cost for
accessing memory on the non lieu
non-local humanoid IO hence the name so
the processor that's plugged into the
socket will have a larger l3 cache that
might be in the megabytes and the
processor will have multiple physical
cores each of those physical calls has
an l1 and an l2 cache which are getting
smaller as you go up the stack and
running on the physical cause is
construct called a hardware thread or
hyper thread and that's the unit that
the operating system can work with so
when you open your system monitor GUI
and you see that you've got four CPUs
all churning away rendering web pages
it's talking about hyper Thirds at that
point and on pretty much almost all
modern systems they will be sharing a
physical core and the physical resources
associated with that core namely the l1
and l2 cache so hold that in your mind
and will refer back to it a bit later
our operating systems are multi tasking
okay we will generally have more tasks
than we have a number of hyper threads
or units to do some processing so you
know if you run PS or look at top or
something like that there's always going
to be more things in the list and there
are CPUs on your box so the OS has to
share out the hardware resources mainly
the CPUs amongst any tasks that have
become runnable and need to get CPU time
so there's a question about how the OS
should do this we probably would like in
the perfect world it to be clever and
fast but that would kind of imply a lot
of knowledge on the operating systems
behalf about how you actually want to
run your application for it so fair is
the what we end up with so the default
and schedule are in Linux is the
completely fair share jeweler so it's
even in the name and this works by
maintaining an order data structure of
tasks per hyper thread and I quote queue
because it's not really cute I think a
ordered B+ tree or something and what
happens is when the scheduler runs for a
given CPU it will pick the task from the
order structure with the lowest run time
I mean that happens to be the head and
it will put that task on to the CPU when
it's runnable after that task comes off
the CPU either because it's used up is
in quantum or because some it's called
schedule or something else has happened
to take it off the scheduler will update
the tasks run time and then it will
place it back into the data structure
and it will because of the orders from
nature of the data structure find its
right place
given its runtime so far we can use
programs like nice to set the priority
of a thread which seems like a great
idea if you want to kind of make sure
your thread is always going ahead of
other stuff but in CFS this really is
just a hint to the scheduler that says
I'd like you to execute this process for
a bit longer when it gets on CPU I think
in previous surgeries I actually had
some effect on where it was ordered in
the cube now it's just kind of a hint so
it doesn't necessarily do what you would
intuitively expect and tasks allowed
bounced across all the hyper threads in
the schedulers scheduling domains so if
we have a situation where we have two
tasks which become runnable in CPU zeros
task queue then the scheduler when it
wakes up it can schedule one and then
see that we've got another runnable
thread it can migrate it to a different
CPUs queue so that in that way it kind
of tries to keep everything ticking over
nicely and spreading out processes to
where there is resource right we're
going to talk about an example
application in order to kind of discuss
an optimal use case for a reducing
system shift it so what we have here is
a data source which might be a network
card or something similar and a thread
which is reading from the data source
and pushing messages onto a queue this
is a shared memory queue which to other
threads read from so as entries are
added we have a logic thread which is
trying to pull messages down as quickly
as possible it does some stuff in memory
and a journal of thread which in
parallel is pulling messages off the
queue and will write them to a journal
and because we all like determinism and
being able to replay things so this
looks like a nice simple view of the
world if we've got a 48 CPU box surely
we're not going to see any system just
so because all we care about three
threads right so whenever I talk about
these diagrams by the way these are
threads okay so something that can
become runnable on a CPU but this is
idealism and as we all know idealism in
reality our
quite far apart from each other so
what's really happening is your
wonderful small component of a system is
actually running within the language of
runtime so in this case a JVM that will
hold true for other runtimes
and what we have within that runtime are
other threads of execution so it might
be garbage collection threads your
application may have other threads you
may have third-party libraries which
have imported and started up threads so
already the picture is a little bit more
muddy too than our idealized view and it
gets worse so running on the operating
system this is responsible for you know
effectively giving you an environment to
execute your program in we have other
threads which are either other user Len
processes or housekeeping threads that
the operating system will schedule from
time to time so we can see that it's
there's some pressure out there you're
not always going to be able to execute
the threads that you want because the
operating system is trying to juggle
everything for you so this through these
kind of mechanisms just the jitter arise
so if you want to talk about what's our
optimal layout for minimizing latency
what we want to do is try and optimize
for locality so given our very simple
application it's reading from some data
source it's pushing messages into a
shared memory cube and we have a couple
of the threads reading from that cube so
ideally if our data source is a network
card we want to make sure that our
processes are running on the same socket
and Numa node as the network card
connected by PCI so in this case we our
producer thread on one of the CPUs on
socket 0 the first one and now because
we know it's going to be writing into a
chunk of memory the cue we want to make
sure that the other threads which are
reading from that queue and hence chunk
of memory are also in the same NEMA node
because we don't want to pay the cost of
going across the memory interconnect
here and if we're lucky and our queue is
small enough it will fit in l3 cache so
we might not even have to go out to main
memory to read from the queue which is
the ideal case so given that we pack
everything together one other thing
it's worth considering is that these
hyper threads are sharing the resources
of the physical Court that means that if
you're if your core is advertised a
clock rate of 2.4 gigahertz saying you
have two Hardware threads which are
executing kind of concurrently their
instructions will end up getting
interleaved slightly so you'll get a
lower clock rate than that is advertised
you will also suffer cash pollution
effects whereby you know your program
running on hyper threads Eero can flash
the cash that's used by a third one so
what we do for the lowest latency is try
and make sure that only one process was
running per core and we'll see some ways
of doing that in a few moments but
really you're just trying to restrict as
much as possible any kind of
interference with your threads that you
care about so on target deployment for
our wonderful simple application looks
something like this
we're going to deploy our three threads
that we care about for minimizing jitter
to a hyper thread on a distinct core and
we'll make it so that we're not running
any other tasks on the sibling hyper
thread sales come in pairs we're going
to give the operating system a bunch of
other CPUs to do all its housekeeping
tasks on and the any of the kind of run
times threads will give it a different
set of CPU so everything is kind of
nicely compartmentalised
right how do I start simple first off
start with the metal and the the BIOS
settings you get on a server will not be
configured for maximum performance
probably most vendors kind of ship them
with power saving features enabled
because for a large data center usages
where you kind of want to do compute on
demand it's better for power costs and
cooling costs if you throttled down you
know various aspects of the system but
that also has an increase effect on
system latency and jitter so need to
change the BIOS settings and I could
spend the rest of the talk talking about
that so I shall
I'll crack on but this is what we want
to do first because measuring these kind
of effects in the software side is a bit
harder so if you know you've got maximum
performance enabled in your BIOS you'll
be in a good place to start okay so
having sorted out the metal and knowing
roughly what kind of deployment we want
to make for our application codes we
need to discover what's available on the
box because they're all going to differ
in terms of their architecture LS top o
is a very good tool for looking at your
hardware it's part of a package called
HW lock so if you're running Linux you
can go and install that run LS top o on
your laptop and it's an enlightening
picture it displays for you the hyper
threads the physical cores on your
machine the Numa nodes and the piece
area locality of any devices that you
have plugged in and it looks something
like this so this is a two socket system
from one of our production servers the
top socket has got four network cards
and a scuzzy device in it and the bottom
socket has got two network cards in it
and we're gonna zoom in a little bit to
see the cause because that's kind of
what we're more interested in
so zoom Ian Ellis opera is showing hyper
threads so in the parlance of ALS top a
that's a processing unit and this is the
number that would show up on your system
resource monitor or something like that
or if you look in proxy PU info so that
would be CPU 24 but we can see that it's
actually sharing a physical core and
that's that slightly darker gray square
and then it will show you the caches and
their associated sizes so each physical
call here has an l1 cache of 64 K which
is slippers split between instruction
and data 256 K l2 cache there's a shared
15 Meg cache for all the cores at l3 and
so hopefully if our data structures fits
in there will be very good for memory
latency and it shows the new local ram
up at the top which on this box is 32
gig so that's like my other diagram but
flipped upside down and because I did my
diagram first
right so we know what's available what
we need to do now is reserve it and use
it so techniques for doing that I
thought CPUs we can use to isolate CPU
resources this is a boot parameter
supplied to the kernel so you can change
your grub com4
or whatever equivalent for your distro
and so we're going to say to the kernel
I'm going to isolate from you CPUs 0 to
5 and 10 to 13 and then we can use the
task set command to pin our application
to a subset of those CPUs so I'll say
because I'm running a JVM task set - C
10 to 13 Java and this says for the
executable that you're about to execute
an any child for its spawn from it I
want you to restrict the CPUs they run
on to 10 to 13 and then we set the
affinity of our hot application threads
using the shared set affinity system
called and it's just a standard sequel
if you're in non-si context then you'll
need to import some kind of library
which can make the call for you there's
a bunch of open source libraries that
will do that from Java so that all
sounds terrific easy so given our
example deployment we are using shed set
affinity to set our important
application threads the OS will end up
running on everything that's not
specified by ISO CPUs I probably pick
the wrong conference to come up with my
own destroyed set notation that they go
and task set is used to limit the JVM
housekeeping threads and anything else
that's spawned to these CPUs over here
so we seem to have achieved our goal
which is good but there's a problem and
that is that we have taken these CPUs at
the end turned to 13 away from the
scheduler who has this excellent
function of load balancing threads so
what happens is the when we use task set
and we execute the Java command that
executable is executed on CPU 10 and
then any child threads which are spawned
from them also execute on CPU
and there's no schedule er to load
balance those across the remaining four
CPUs so you end up with everything
running on one CPU which is fairly
disastrous so it was a good attempt it
doesn't work so we'll need to find an
alternative so and there are many
solutions I'm sure the one we ended up
pumping for was CPU sets it gave us the
best results so this is just one way of
doing this CPU sets is a program based
on C groups which is a Linux construct
for kind of carving up resources and it
allows us to create hierarchical sets of
reserved resources we can reserve CPU
memory a/c groups can go further into
other devices but leave that for another
day and it has some user lam tools which
a nice C set is the main operator it
comes from the Susi distro but you can
get it built for other distributions and
it will allow us to programmatically do
what we're trying to do before and with
ice or CPU so there's a lot of text here
but the C set set command operates on
sets so this says create a set called
system with CPU 6 to 9 and then we use
the proc move function to move
everything from the root set which is
kind of everything to the system set and
there's a few extra flags that you want
to add to that if you want to try this
out
- kay moves and bound kernel threads so
there are other threads spawned per CPU
by the kernel which will occasionally do
some work they don't actually have to
run there so anything that can be moved
this will shift them - - threads moves
child threads because there's a race
condition in that while a process is
being moved it might spoil a child
thread which would end up on the wrong
CPU set and force does force there's no
documentation of what it does but it
doesn't do any harm so switch that one
I don't think it doesn't harm more thing
okay so schematically we have the root
CPU set which has CPUs 0 to 13 on this
mythical piece of hardware which doesn't
exist anywhere because no one would
choose those numbers and we've created a
system CPU set with CPUs 6 to 9 and
shifted all the processes there so
that's kind of doing the same thing as I
saw CPUs did for us okay after isolating
or getting rid of the OS resources we
now want to run our application in the
same way we did before we're gonna use C
sets again to construct a CPU set called
app and the next thing to do is use the
executive command and we'll say I want
to execute in the app CPU set this
command and then we're using tasks again
to restrict the sort of parent
application to CPUs 10 to 13 and again
using shared set affinity to pin the hot
threads to CPUs 1 3 & 5 so we've gone
from having a root CPU set which
contained everything to the system 1
we've shifted stuff there and we've
created an app CPU set where we're going
to run our program and that looks like
this so we're using shed set affinity in
the app CPU set because we're now in
control of what's being scheduled in app
we know that nothing else is going to be
put on the sibling hyper cause hyper
thread Sri all the OS stuff runs in
flash system and using tasks set to
restrict and the runtime and it's child
threads everything's going to run on
those CPUs there now the nice thing
about this is because CPU sets is
effectively just creating a new
scheduling domain for the scheduler to
work within we now get proper load
balancing across the CPUs at the end
there so the whole VM on one CPU problem
has gone away which is good
no more Jessa
so this is all this kind of makes
intuitive sense I guess like you know
you're you're taking your threads that
you care about and you're giving them as
much resource as possible but being good
scientists we want to kind of have some
kind of experiment confirm our findings
and so if if we'd been doing our
measurements end-to-end we I expect that
you would see a fair bit of improvement
after doing this kind of work for
application because you know there's
going to be a lot less scheduling
pressure on them now but we only look a
little bit deeper just to make sure
there's nothing else going on so at this
point we can turn to one of the Linux
traces called Perth events
it's a sampling tracer in the Linux
kernel so it just kind of samples events
for you when you tell it to it can use
the static trace points which are
compiled into the kernel source if you
build with config debug it also has the
possibility of inserting dynamic trace
points into libraries which is pretty
cool it's very low overhead because if
it's something nature so it's it's quite
good for looking at a system under load
and knowing that you're very unlikely to
perturb the system and cause some real
effects just by trying to inspect it
it's not Heisenberg it's good starting
point for Deeping digging deeper so
because it's a sampler you don't get
everything but over time you can build
up a picture of what's going on and it
will tend to give you a hint of where
you want to go and look next once it's
installed perfo lists will show all the
available trace points also does
hardware counters and hardware events
that I'm not going to cover here and
there's lots of different classes of
event groups so this stuff for network
stuff with file systems or the scheduler
and we're going to be looking at regular
events because we know the scheduler is
responsible for moving tasks on and off
CPU so we can use that to make sure that
our assumptions hold true so we can ask
a CPU what's happening and the way we're
going to do that is by running this
command and this says to perf I would
like you to sample all the tasks which
events emitted by the scheduler on CPU
three so if we remember from our diagram
I think that's the one that has the
logic thread on it so we're hoping that
there shouldn't be any tasks of
scratching
that's bad and introduces jitter once
you've captured some data perf report is
will take that binary file and render it
into human readable format and perf
reports really good if you've got
multiple different event types you can
use it to kind of drill through and
it'll tell you percentages of what
counts of events and things like that if
you just got a single event and you just
want to see the stream perf script
basically just dumps the event trace for
you which is best for this case so this
is the output from trying to record
share sort of shed switch events on that
CPU while this application was running
although it can immediately see is that
we've got two processors so there is
task switching going on so just looking
at what's contained in that event first
off it tells us the program that was
executing when the scheduler emitted
this event I've got the pig this is the
timestamp to microsecond precision which
and I think it's uptime in seconds since
the debug file system was mounted so you
can work backwards and roughly convert
it to wall time but it's a bit never
quite exact and then this is the event
so we were only recording shed switch
events so this is all we're going to see
and then each event kind of has a printf
format associated with it so they all
have different and parameters when they
print out so for shared switch events
what we see is that the the process that
was moved off the CPU was this pig
running with that priority and it's
state was runnable so it wasn't ready to
yield the processor it wanted to
continue consuming CPU time but it was
kicked off in favour of K worker program
which was the thing that was then
scheduled on and we can see from the
timestamp so and so that was that was
our Java process being kicked off and
then a few microseconds later the K
worker thread moves off again and Java
is put back onto the CPU and the Delta
there is about five microseconds so not
a large amount of time but you know our
process was taken off the cpu at state
had to be saved something else was moved
on which could invalidate caches and
then our Java process got back on to
continue its work so it's going to have
some kind of effect on how how quickly
we can process messages and and this bit
here is telling us that the K worker
thread was in the sleep state when it
came off so what happened by the looks
of it it was woken up and scheduled its
fans that have no work to do and
immediately put itself to sleep and that
sort of cycle took five microseconds so
not a lot in this case so now we've got
some evidence that our world is not the
happy place we thought it was and we're
still got contention for CPU resources
so one approach we could take is to try
and find out what is this thing doing
why is it being put onto the CPU to do
that because it's good to introduce
these things we could use F trace which
is another limits kernel tracer this is
the function tracer it uses the same
static and dynamic trace points as
performance it has a much higher it has
a higher overhead because it records
everything into percy pu ring buffers so
it kind of puts that and responsibility
onto you or executing program but it
captures everything so if you are more
interested once you've built up a kind
of a broad picture using perf and you
want to actually focus on something very
specific F traces is the point where you
can start recording everything to see
what's going on and it can provide
function graphs of kernel function calls
which is something that's very cool if
you like that kind of thing
there's a thing you'd actually want to
install the trace command otherwise it's
just echoing values into file systems in
the debug file system which is well you
can crash box is quite a lot doing that
whereas this at least makes an attempt
to and stop you from shooting yourself
in the foot right so we could use this
function tracer to have a look at what
that K worker thread is doing okay and
to do that we'd use trace of command
record and this says I would like you to
choice trace all kernel functions that
are being called by the process
specified by pit now we know what okay
worker threads pitties so we can run
this leave it running for
you know how long we need to and then
control see it and it will write some
data to a binary file locally whereupon
we can use trace command report which
will display the capture trace data in
something remotely like human readable
format and that looks like this so what
we can see is that the K worker thread
was executing on CPU 3 which is what we
expect we have the same microsecond
precision timestamps and it will show us
essentially the method calls in the
kernel source code which are executed so
these function names up here you can go
and have a look in the kernel source
code and they exist and F trace the
function graph plug-in will tell you how
long a sort of a method call of depth
one took so you can see our x there in
their sort of hundreds of nanoseconds or
tens of nanoseconds and the other really
nice feature is that when it pops out of
a block of code it will report to you
the cumulative time that's spent in a
block of code so this is interesting we
can see that the process one work
function which contained a function
called cache Reap and i've elided a load
of lines there took 86 microseconds so
before we saw that our process was only
switched out for five microseconds here
it was 86 which is somewhat more
significant no that's slightly higher
than it would be if we hadn't been
tracing because you're pushing some
overhead onto the executing process
there in this case the cache root
function we can't actually defer it if
this was worked but it is necessary to
be done so we'd have to find other ways
around this problem so that's a very
brief Whistlestop tour of how to use
traces to look for system disah so when
trying to reduce disser in the limit
service there's a few good things to
look out for and one is the cache read
function which was just seen that's a
property of the slab allocator which has
been replaced in more recent kernels
with the slub allocator which doesn't
have to execute these recurrent jobs per
CPU when we were doing our in to end
tests and we made a change to the sub
allocator we saw that I mean latency
actually crept up a little bit
so it wasn't intuitive but we found that
the slave labor kata was fast enough for
our use case that it was better to have
this periodic interruption which happens
every two seconds or so so there's
another good reason for having your
end-to-end test though and be able to
compare these kind of things because
intuitively it should be better if our
threads are not being kicked off the CPU
but for whatever reasons that was a bit
faster the VM star update function will
be executed on every CPU every second
this is something the kernel does to
generate stats so you load averages and
things like that other work queue events
the the K worker thread is there's one
of them per CPU they they're bound
kernel threads you can't move them and
there's sort of a general dumping ground
for work that needs to be done on the
kernels behalf so now that we kind of
know we're looking at work queues we
could use the perf events starting with
work queue and that would allow us to
see any other kind of working events
that are going on there so we've kind of
seen that there was a thread which is
being executed we found out what its
function is and what it's doing and then
found a class of events which we can
trace to see okay and I now want to see
all the kind of work that's being queued
and then we can try and research if
there's a way to minimize the cost of
those interrupts whenever a hardware
device fires an interrupt that's going
to be surfaced on one of the CPUs in
your system and be chosen by the driver
and probably and you you can't stop
there interrupting your process so this
is something that we also want to stop
it's possible to set the affinity of the
our queues in the proc file system so
you can at least you have to be a bit
careful about where you put them but you
can at least try and stop them from
firing on the CPUs where you really care
about latency timer ticks are they're
kind of an interrupt as well you can't
move their affinity they're going to
happen and there is a config setting
when you build your kernel that says how
often you want each CPU to be
interrupted on our servant machines it's
a thousand times a second on my laptop I
think it's every four milliseconds and
but
this is seems a problem for a long time
so there's some work from the real-time
patch set merged into the mainline
kernel a while ago that does something
called tick list mode where if the shed
you'll notice is that there's only a
single runnable thread on your CPU and
there's nothing else in the task queue
and it will just turn off ticks for that
CPU for a given amount of time and using
that and what we see is that you can
then run for several seconds without any
kind of interruption on your CPU
otherwise you'll be getting your process
will be kicked off by the hardware
interrupt a thousand times a second
which isn't ideal CPU speed the our
laptops and our servers again they're
kind of built for trying to minimize
power draw and cooling costs so the
default settings for these kind of
things will be to scale down CPU speed
to try and reduce power draw there's
file systems on modern kernels where you
can go and change these kind of things
to basically turn them up to 11 so that
they're always stressing the fan so
there's just a few things that you're
going to come up against mmm so I've
pushed a load of information and I'm
going to talk about some numbers now
because so you could all do with a break
so we're going to use inter thread
latency as a proxy for system jitter so
we're gonna and this is what the example
application that I talked about actually
does it essentially is passing a message
from one thread to another thread which
has been he's busy spinning trying to
wait to receive that message and if we
look at the time taking between the
producer and the consumer through that
queue that will give us a rough idea of
the jitter signal within our system so
if we run it and we record those times
over several seconds we can then kind of
build up a distribution of what kind of
jitter we're getting in our system and
then we can compare the untuned and the
tune system and see are these techniques
any good do they actually do anything
mmm so the numbers these are nanosecond
values for inter thread latency the
untuned system is actually not bad on
this box but you can see that the the
tune values for the mean
is about double and then we just kind of
list them for increasing percentiles but
pretty much every case it's double for
the untuned system in the time taken to
get between those two threads and the
max here is the same because there was
some event on that system that happened
to take that hit both those runs and I
saw what it was but with the chain
system it should have been a bit lower
so a picture just to show you how that
looks and what I don't report is
anything past the four nines on those
those number charts so you can see here
that the red line is the tuned
application the Green Line is the
untuned application so it's still into
thread latency
we've got nanoseconds on the y axis and
then it's log scale for each of the
percentiles going out so you can see
they tend to diverge quite rapidly after
about the four nines if you look about
in a log scale you can see that no
matter where you take the measurement
you just about you're always doing
better in the teen system so you're
always going to get less jitter wherever
you are so this these numbers are not
terribly impressive you know we're still
talking you know in the in the tens
twenties or hundreds of microseconds but
these tests were run on a 64 CPU box
that had had all the right by all
settings put on it and was effectively
idle so it was it was running a you know
stop clinics where it wasn't really
doing much so there was no scheduling
pressure but in the real world that's
not going to be the case so these kind
of techniques are really useful when you
have especially if you have to deal with
bursty workloads so you can imagine
you've got part of your application
which you want to run really fast but
you also have to service bursts of
traffic or maybe lots of inbound network
connections and your systems behavior
might be to spin up a load of threads to
deal with those inbound connections and
then suddenly you've got contention for
your CPU resource and scheduling
pressure which is not evident in the
numbers are shown so far so if we modify
the application so that it spins up a
thread per CPU that wakes up every I
don't know 10 or 13 milliseconds I think
and does a busy spin for a little while
we're effectively introducing a real
workload where we will get shuddering
pressure and there this method starts to
come in handy a bit more so this is a
loaded system where we're just
effectively every 30
also trying to push our important
threads off the CPU occasionally now the
unchain system our max latency between
two threads goes up to over 800
microseconds and the four lines is a lot
higher as well whereas the chain system
is staying pretty much straight down the
line really good latency and this is
because we've all our tunings have
effectively reserved the CPU resource
that we want and we know that we're not
going to get any spurious shedding
pressure that's going to kick us off the
CPU and a bit more instructive there and
so we can see the red line is the tuned
system untuned after the three nines
just goes through the roof at that point
your users are not having a good day so
although on a very quiet system it
doesn't look so impressive if you do
this kind of thing when you've actually
got some real load you'll you'll see a
much bigger difference there right
so in summary select threads that need
access to CPU and if your application
has important work that needs to be done
and done in a low latency manner
identify what those processes are take
some CPUs from the OS hopefully you've
got enough CPUs for the threads that you
need to be low latency if you haven't by
a bigger box or shard pin the important
threads to those isolated CPUs so that
you know you're not going to get any
contention and don't forget about
interrupts which can cause you jitter
that we load small things I've covered
just a few but it's a it's like an
endless learning process and always
always always test your assumptions so
probably the most important slides are
about making sure you can measure it
when you're making changes and the tools
you can use to check that your
assumptions are actually valid and that
there's not something else happening on
the system that you don't know about
right and there's we blog about this
kind of stuff for Lmax so if you're
interested in low latency and high
performance stuff and there'll be some
interesting blogs you might like to read
and there's a github repo which has the
example application and a walkthrough of
these kind of techniques so you can try
it out and see if it you can get some
interesting numbers or if it works for
you and if you want to talk come and
grab me or give me a line on twitter
thank you very much